we have breaking nfl news the washington
redskins confirmed that the team will
get
a new name the move comes after renewed
calls from
activists plus some high-profile
sponsors
to abandon the long-standing nickname
that many view as
racist jan crawford is following the
story in washington jan
has the franchise revealed its new name
yet well now the new name
has not yet been released because of
some pending trademark issues but
for native american advocacy groups who
have been pushing for this for
decades this is a long time coming the
franchise's majority owner dan snyder
has been resistant to changing the
team's 87 year old name but under
growing financial pressure snyder said
earlier this month he was going to
conduct a thorough review of the name
amid a renewed national conversation
about race
now last week espn reported the team was
giving up all
native american imagery but it's going
to keep the team colors of burgundy and
gold other sports teams they're
also responding to some of this renewed
scrutiny baseball's
atlanta braves told fans they will not
be changing their name
but they're going to re-examine the use
of the tomahawk chop
cheer by fans some activists say that
cheer perpetuates this
warrior savage myth and then the ice
hockey team chicago blackhawks
it's also standing behind its name their
reason
they say that honors the native american
leader and war
chief blackhawk it's an honor they say
who has been an inspiration
to generations jan thanks